foreign
[Music]
these dragons are a highly evolved
species they are aggressive prehistoric
reptiles which act as the monster
antagonists of the movie Reign of Fire
and also in the video game adaptation
these dragons evolved during the
Cretaceous Period from a yet unknown
ancestor species they are the ones that
have been theorized to have wiped out
the dinosaurs and then went into
hibernation for 66 million years only be
woken up in 2002 in London so let's talk
a little bit on their timeline and
history so let's say around 66 million
years ago a prior species of dragon
underwent a rapid evolutionary
transition from a simple flying reptile
to one that has the ability to breathe
fire as well as devour Ash as a part of
its diet this evolutionary Advantage was
furthered by a rapid reproductive cycle
which made them overcome the dinosaurs
and put them to Extinction so it is also
theorized that when their food source
was depleted they went into a death-like
sleep slumbering for millions of years
not unlike Cthulhu living in a deathless
slumber but some of them mostly females
were awakened by Humanity in the past
which became the legends of the Dragons
of the Viking age and the Middle Ages
and many of them were slaughtered by
Vikings and knights in Europe then in
2002 the male was awakened and went
around the world Awakening the large
number of females in hibernation and
with the Abundant food supply they were
able to reproduce at a very rapid rate
in the months and years following the
dragon's Awakening mankind attempted to
resist them using their combined
military strength including nuclear
bombs in 2010 but this only expedited
the planet's downfall and Humanity was
nearly wiped out within a few years
so that's their history now let's
discuss about the male and female
dragons in this universe their
morphology and differences so the female
dragon is much smaller than a male
dragon the females are typically 12 to
15 meters or 45 to 50 feet long with a
wingspan of twice that but the males are
more than twice longer than the females
with a wingspan that is twice as wide
the facial variations between the Sexes
are minor yet substantial while the
females upper horns are straighter the
males lengthier upper horns are more
girl the male's lower horns are
significantly shorter than a female's
while the female's lips and nostrils are
longer than the males but the most
noticeable differences is the sexual
dimorphism which has their size
so about their Anatomy these dragons can
be defined as fire breathing wyverns as
they have full number of Limbs two at
the back which have developed into
powerful clawed feet and two in front
which have evolved into wings with the
digits elongated and the web skin
between them acting as the leathery
Wings their body is very Serpentine slim
and very Sleek with a very long tail
they have small spikes on their backs
and a scaly underbelly they produce a
flame via chemicals produced in two
glands in the back of their mouths on
either side of their tongues and then
when they are mixed together it proves
to be highly combustible these chemicals
are also very toxic to humans just on
their own their diet is the most unique
trait that isn't seen in any other
adaptation of dragon's in fiction these
dragons hunt their prey by stalking them
from the air and then launching at them
from above then when they catch their
prey they burn them using their flame
and then Devour the ashes it isn't just
animals that are devout this way but
even forests and plants be species so
after scorching the Earth and there's no
food supply anywhere the dragons will
then resort to cannibalism and devour
each other at this time the enormous
male dragon would be the main apex
predator and the females would become
his prey this will happen till the
females Retreat back into the ground for
hibernation and when the food source
becomes negligible then the male will
also go back to sleep now we come to
their life cycle so there are theories
that say that even the male dragon can
lay eggs and hence produce the females
but we are just gonna brush that aside
the most probable theory is that it flew
around the world Awakening the females
and with them at his side they started
to reproduce eggs and the male
fertilizes them to make more females
after a female dragon has matured into
an adult the male dragon will impregnate
them even if they are his daughters it
is said that in every Colony there is a
single male and multiple females the
male will grow bigger than females to
protect him from being overcome by
hungry females in times of food scarcity
as he is clearly the species sole hope
of survival anyway after a female is
impregnated the Mother Dragon will lay
her egg in usually a protected man-made
structure such as a fort to create a
nest and deposit her eggs three female
dragons were discovered to be nesting
within a sea Fort at the same time so
these dragons are kind of like a hive
species a large brood of juvenile and
adult female dragons will be present
inside the nesting area to protect the
nest and egg and also they will fly
above it the eggs are 45 centimeters by
20 centimeters in size which means they
are very sleek and oval in shape most of
the dragon eggs will house a developing
female embryo while in a rare occasion a
male will develop and a cycle goes on
when the food is abundant but if not
they will go into another different
stage and this stage is their prolonged
hibernation which as I said earlier is
more like a deathless slumber a
lovecraftian trade sleeping for millions
of years like Cthulhu while not becoming
fossilized or decomposed by fungi and
bacteria this would mean that their body
is inedible by anything natural this
makes the dragons biologically Immortal
which means that they would not die of
old age or disease but only be killed by
physical Falls anyway it is theorized
that at the end of the movie the dragons
went back into the ground as the food
source was all but gone which means that
in the future they may emerge again so I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam